hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
today I saw that Apple announced some
new emojis now these will be out in a
future release of iOS 11 they did give
us a very small preview of some new ones
on world emoji day but today they gave
us even more so I kind of looked at them
very quickly especially the animals but
I wanted to do sort of a reaction to
them make sure you guys leave me some
comments below and let me know what your
favorite old emoji is and also what your
favorite new emoji is and the best part
about this is you can comment with an
emoji if you guys don't have an iOS
device that's okay we can still see your
emojis and you can still see ours so
make sure you guys comment and let me
know what your favorite is the first law
we have is a sign language for I love
you which is awesome I was also reading
this has been a very highly requested
emoji and guess what
here it is next this is legendary and to
go with the giraffe and the zebra I
recently went to nap oh we did this
really cool Safari where we saw giraffes
and zebras and I was trying to tweet
about it and I realized what there's no
giraffe or zebra emoji but guess what
else there is a porcupine a dinosaur
cricket animal I think this is a
dumpling or like a we call them
pierogies does anybody know what a
pierogi is bronies are pretty famous in
Pittsburgh they even have at the Pirates
games which is our baseball team they
have pierogi races or they have these
people dressed up in costumes and they
chase each other around the field it's
kind of silly I'm not sure if they still
do that it's been a very long time since
I've been to a Pirates game oh we've got
some delicious takeout food this is
interesting this is a piece of broccoli
a little broccoli floret preview Oh a
future video
I wonder what type of pie this is
supposed to be because this could really
be any type of pie it could be an apple
pie it could be a chicken pot pie but
let me tell you what it probably isn't
it's probably not a pumpkin pie and you
know how I know this because I made a
really big mistake and you guys will see
this in a Thanksgiving ish video I tried
to make a pumpkin pie did you guys know
the pumpkin pies don't normally have
crust on top of them you think that's
something that is very common knowledge
it's something that I didn't realize
next up we have this beautiful very very
luxurious blue hat I wonder if they're
gonna have the option to press down on
it and choose different colored hats
probably not but if they did that's a
pretty cool idea oh and look at this
wonderful red scarf I wonder if they'll
do that same thing for this I don't
think they will I feel like this is
probably a standard-issue color but that
would be really cool if they did that
oops I lost more I was some winter
gloves a beautiful jacket I actually
like that jacket it's very chic very
detective like these next ones are
pretty awesome and a huge props to Apple
for taking a stand and saying guess what
we're gonna do this
they have non-gender emojis so these are
amazing so here's one here's the next
and here's the third I think it's pretty
cool let me know what you guys think I
next in addition to all the other heart
emojis they have a new orange heart I'd
say probably my favorite part out of all
of them is the black one and the purple
next we've got this a wonderful wizard
we have a not really sure what they're
calling us but it kind of looks like a
little Tinkerbell a vampire which is
perfect timing for Halloween and a
mermaid I feel like this is definitely
long overdue here's a few of the new
face emojis we've got that somewhat I'm
not really sure what's going on this
little guy
he's just kind of like this I definitely
use all the time it's the Shh emoji I
feel like there's so many times when
well probably my sister will mostly use
it on me I'll just be yappin about
something
it's gonna be the perfect time from one
of the Shh emojis this is also very
interesting because it's one two three
four five five character swear word and
I'm going through the list of swear
words that could possibly be and I feel
like most of the really bad ones or four
letters so it's kind of a good thing
that it's five letters because more or
less like you know we're not saying a
bad bad word we're just saying they're
not sure I would say comment below but
the smart word that you think it is but
I do not want you to do that and I have
swear words block just so you can't say
them anyway my company this one I like a
lot I love the little eyeglass guy this
is one of those things that I feel like
me and my sister will use when we're not
that we would ever do this but if we
were to say you know stopping somebody
on the internet creeping on their
Instagram or on their Twitter this is
one of the perfect emojis for that and
we never ever do that and you guys
probably don't do that ever like come on
this is a little sled this is in kind of
like the health and fitness wellness
section I guess I'm not really sure I
mean I feel like this is one of those
things like I don't mmm I'm not really
under percent sure I'm just rambling now
we can try to figure out what the sled
is for I mean is this like a dog sled is
this like a fitness sled where you like
put things on and then you push it and
pull it and get will fit I'm something
really sure with the saddest thing is
that something else for fitness go like
this
when you're doing lick push-ups or
something I will say I probably will use
this one more than once or twice this is
a beautiful spa emoji and the last one
here on my list is a rock climber well
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed this quick little iOS
preview I was so excited when I saw that
they had new emojis coming out obviously
we've been waiting for this for a really
long time Apple has been teasing this
for months I mean maybe even it's almost
been a year at this point I mean there's
so many emojis that it takes me longer
to scroll through and find the one that
I want but what it's made it so much
easier is in iOS you can just type the
emoji that you're looking for so for
example giraffe I can type that what
this is actually out the little giraffe
mode you will pop-up below in the little
predictive text you can click it and
then you don't have to scroll through
all of them anyway I will see you guys
soon I have a GoPro Hero comparison
video coming out very soon and I think I
mention it on Twitter the image
stabilization is amazing I'll also have
a week or I guess at this point it's two
weeks with iPhone 8 video I've got some
fun cooking videos for Halloween coming
out and let's see I think there's
something else too but I don't remember
at this point I'll see you in the next
one don't forget to subscribe if you're
not already and that's all I'm gonna go
out of this video
[Music]